thank you next time we say I said that
men had to have 25 000 to be in the
relationship right and Everywhere I Go
people always ask me like TK we ain't
got that kind of money not that much
money respectfully let me explain to you
and I told this guy going through the
airport he asked me this this other day
see my philosophy is really for the
young kids them kids 14 15 loving me
because them young boys like yo I rock
with you because I want to understand
stack your money it's like going to
college or buying your first house the
25 000 because they thought I meant give
the female 25 000. no the 25 000 is for
you
because when you got a little change
your chasing hoes is different when you
got a little change you move through
differently most men [__] with a girl
because she dropped dead gorgeous
that's true but don't bring that into
the table yeah see because ads don't pay
the bills I mean
ass don't pay the bills I mean unless
you got a girl doing only fans or
whatever I'm sure there's a few a few
problems yeah for sure yeah but even if
you have the money what's your character
now I was gonna say that there's there's
a there's a takeaway in other avenues if
the ass is paying the bills it's a cat
or your character
um one time I was talking about women
using too much profanity yeah they're
getting upset now I know no man
but thinks that's hot that'll bring his
girl around his grandparents right
around his mother and a girl every other
word is using profanity now to the
ladies listening nobody here is trying
to tell you what to do what I'm saying
is I'm not saying you shouldn't curse
I'm saying curse when you're really
upset when it means something because I
look at women as being the most
beautiful women on the planet and you
never know who's watching you right and
there's another girl watching the way
you move through life
whether you know it or not and if you
use a profoundly you acting a fool
you're really
guiding her if she see you doing it
because it's cool but if you say move a
certain way that girl gonna move
straight away so all women have to be
responsible for each other because when
women move a certain way and move with
dignity move a class it's domino effect
other women want to be that way yep you
know and that's in